Speaker 1: So non-duality is the beginning and the end
Speaker 1: of the entire discussion about
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: The search for non-duality is the search
Speaker 1: for the ultimate truth about the nature of
Speaker 1: reality.
Speaker 1: So it's not a small subject.
Speaker 1: So it's a search for the ultimate truth
Speaker 1: about the nature of reality.
Speaker 1: And, as I'm fond of repeating, the
Speaker 1: Buddhists make a very compelling
Speaker 1: distinction that I always find helpful and
Speaker 1: inspiring, and they make a distinction
Speaker 1: between two different levels of reality.
Speaker 1: And they make a distinction between two
Speaker 1: different levels of reality One level of
Speaker 1: reality being, which is called relative
Speaker 1: reality, which is relatively real, and
Speaker 1: another level of reality which is the level
Speaker 1: of the absolute or the absolute reality.
Speaker 1: So there's a distinction, there's this very
Speaker 1: interesting distinction between relative
Speaker 1: reality, relative cognition, relative
Speaker 1: experience, relative knowing and absolute
Speaker 1: reality, in which we experience absolute
Speaker 1: cognition and absolute knowing.
Speaker 1: So it's when we take the leap from relative
Speaker 1: cognition and relative knowing to absolute
Speaker 1: cognition and absolute knowing that we
Speaker 1: glimpse what universally has been
Speaker 1: considered to be the highest level of
Speaker 1: reality and the highest truth, which is the
Speaker 1: ultimate truth of non-duality.
Speaker 1: So the ultimate truth of non-duality, so
Speaker 1: the ultimate truth of non-duality, tells us
Speaker 1: that the final answer to all questions?
Speaker 1: The final answer to all spiritual questions
Speaker 1: is that the ultimate nature of reality, the
Speaker 1: ultimate nature of the truth, is that
Speaker 1: there's only one and not two, is that
Speaker 1: there's only one and not two.
Speaker 1: And we're told that the experience of that
Speaker 1: undivided oneness, which is not two-ness,
Speaker 1: is the source of liberation and the source
Speaker 1: of the awakening to enlightened awareness,
Speaker 1: the source of the experience of
Speaker 1: enlightenment itself, the source of the
Speaker 1: experience that all of the most realized
Speaker 1: masters have spoken to us about.
Speaker 1: So before I speak about the evolution of
Speaker 1: non-duality, I just want to speak a little
Speaker 1: bit about non-duality itself.
Speaker 1: So, before I speak about the evolution of
Speaker 1: non-duality, I just want to speak a little
Speaker 1: bit about non-duality itself, because it's
Speaker 1: very subtle and it's not so easy to see,
Speaker 1: because we're used to seeing objects that
Speaker 1: exist outside of ourselves.
Speaker 1: We're used to seeing things.
Speaker 1: We're not used to perceiving reality as a
Speaker 1: whole, but we're used to seeing objects
Speaker 1: that appear in reality.
Speaker 1: So the experience of non-duality is when we
Speaker 1: have a direct gnosis or a direct knowing of
Speaker 1: the meta-context of everything that exists
Speaker 1: and everything that doesn't exist.
Speaker 1: It's a meta-context of everything that
Speaker 1: exists and everything that does not exist,
Speaker 1: and it is a seeing and a knowing and a
Speaker 1: recognition in which there's no subject and
Speaker 1: there's no object.
Speaker 1: So it's very difficult to understand with
Speaker 1: the mind, it's very difficult to understand
Speaker 1: with the intellect, it's impossible to
Speaker 1: understand with the ego.
Speaker 1: So it's very tricky, it's very slippery,
Speaker 1: it's very subtle, it's very mysterious.
Speaker 1: And it's very slippery, it's very subtle,
Speaker 1: it's very mysterious and it's very absolute.
Speaker 1: So one of the many reasons why this is such
Speaker 1: a difficult topic and such a difficult
Speaker 1: experience to grasp is because we can say,
Speaker 1: from a certain point of view, that this
Speaker 1: truth exists everywhere and nowhere
Speaker 1: simultaneously.
Speaker 1: And the reason that most of us have so much
Speaker 1: trouble getting non-duality, really getting
Speaker 1: it very deeply, getting a real, deep, solid,
Speaker 1: stable understanding to it, of it, it's
Speaker 1: because we have been trained in the way
Speaker 1: we've been trained in the art of perception
Speaker 1: and the art of cognition to see objects.
Speaker 1: We've been taught, through the way we've
Speaker 1: been educated by our parents and by our
Speaker 1: system of learning, to focus more on
Speaker 1: objects than on context.
Speaker 1: So the search for enlightenment, which is
Speaker 1: the search for non-duality or the ultimate
Speaker 1: oneness that's not two is the search for
Speaker 1: the ultimate and absolute context for all
Speaker 1: experience and non-experience.
Speaker 1: This is the search for the meta-context in
Speaker 1: which everything that exists and everything
Speaker 1: that doesn't exist appear and disappear.
Speaker 1: So if we've been trained since day one to
Speaker 1: look at objects and not at context, it's
Speaker 1: going to be very difficult for us to awaken
Speaker 1: to the ultimate metacontext in which all
Speaker 1: things exist and don't exist.
Speaker 1: So this is why, in all the training, in all
Speaker 1: the spiritual training that is designed to
Speaker 1: help us to awaken to non-duality, we're
Speaker 1: always told to stop looking at objects and
Speaker 1: stop trying to see anything particular.
Speaker 1: And a lot of people find it very
Speaker 1: frustrating because they say well I'm, if I
Speaker 1: let go of objects and I stop trying to see
Speaker 1: anything, what am I supposed to be doing?
Speaker 1: Because we're told that the experience of
Speaker 1: life that includes conscious self-awareness
Speaker 1: is always by doing something, getting from
Speaker 1: point A to point B.
Speaker 1: And we say no, if you want to discover the
Speaker 1: ultimate metacontext or absolute context
Speaker 1: for all experience and non-experience, you
Speaker 1: have to stop looking for anything at all.
Speaker 1: Stop looking for anything.
Speaker 1: But if you're trying to stop looking for
Speaker 1: anything with your ego mind, you're going
Speaker 1: to experience enormous frustration.
Speaker 1: A lot of people do.
Speaker 1: You've all heard me tell this story many
Speaker 1: times about this experience I had with my
Speaker 1: teacher when I returned to see him after
Speaker 1: several months and walked into the room and
Speaker 1: saw him and he smiled and said Andrew, I'm
Speaker 1: so happy you found a friend that you'll
Speaker 1: never be able to see.
Speaker 1: I'm so happy you found a friend that you'll
Speaker 1: I'm so happy you found a friend you'll
Speaker 1: never be able to see.
Speaker 1: I'm so very happy you found a friend you'll
Speaker 1: So in the search for enlightenment, which
Speaker 1: is the search for your own true self, if
Speaker 1: you're successful in your search, if you
Speaker 1: find what you're looking for, if you find
Speaker 1: what you're looking for and there's a very
Speaker 1: clear distinction between being a seeker
Speaker 1: and a finder so if you actually found what
Speaker 1: you're looking for, if you've reached the
Speaker 1: yonder shore and put your feet on that warm
Speaker 1: sand, then you have found that friend
Speaker 1: you'll never be able to see.
Speaker 1: So so something big happens when we become
Speaker 1: more interested in the ultimate context for
Speaker 1: all experience and non-experience than we
Speaker 1: are in the objects that exist all around us.
Speaker 1: Because when you actually wake up to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness and you discover this
Speaker 1: metacontext or absolute context, which is
Speaker 1: the leap from relative reality and relative
Speaker 1: consciousness and cognition to absolute
Speaker 1: reality and absolute consciousness and
Speaker 1: cognition, you discover, to your delight
Speaker 1: and to your surprise, that this
Speaker 1: meta-context is speaking to you and
Speaker 1: revealing truths and perspectives and ways
Speaker 1: of knowing and unknowing and ways of
Speaker 1: cognition, types of cognition that are
Speaker 1: simply unavailable in relative
Speaker 1: consciousness and relative cognition and
Speaker 1: relative knowing.
Speaker 1: So one way we could say it is to let go of
Speaker 1: everything so you can see the totality of
Speaker 1: all things, so you can see the totality of
Speaker 1: all things.
Speaker 1: Let go of everything so you can see the
Speaker 1: totality of all things.
Speaker 1: But the totality of all things is not a
Speaker 1: thing.
Speaker 1: When we use language, we always speak in
Speaker 1: terms of seeing objects, we think of seeing
Speaker 1: something, but the metacognition of
Speaker 1: absolute reality is not seeing anything
Speaker 1: particular.
Speaker 1: It's a knowing of non-relative or absolute
Speaker 1: gnosis of non-relative or absolute gnosis.
Speaker 1: It's a mysterious kind of metacognition,
Speaker 1: understanding and knowing in which all of
Speaker 1: our human and relative concerns and fears
Speaker 1: and desires are all abated, they fall away
Speaker 1: from us and we, at least temporarily,
Speaker 1: become unconcerned with everything we're
Speaker 1: afraid of, with everything we think we want,
Speaker 1: because we're so stunned with the
Speaker 1: revelation and gnosis of that which is
Speaker 1: absolute and unrelative.
Speaker 1: The revelation of absolute reality answers
Speaker 1: all of our questions, including the
Speaker 1: questions we didn't even know we had.
Speaker 1: It quiets us down, it calms our heart and
Speaker 1: soul and relieves us of all of our fears
Speaker 1: and our existential doubts and worries in a
Speaker 1: way that nothing else can.
Speaker 1: It's like coming home.
Speaker 1: Now, how we approach this kind of
Speaker 1: experience is not really important.
Speaker 1: Some methods claim to be instantaneous and
Speaker 1: others claim that they take time and
Speaker 1: practice.
Speaker 1: And it doesn't really matter how you
Speaker 1: approach this enormous existential and
Speaker 1: metaphysical challenge, but what's
Speaker 1: important is that you actually succeed.
Speaker 1: It's important that you actually succeed
Speaker 1: and have the breakthrough.
Speaker 1: It changes everything.
Speaker 1: And it's also important to gain access to
Speaker 1: metacognition and to gnosis and absolute
Speaker 1: reality on a regular basis, because what's
Speaker 1: the metacontext in which the experience of
Speaker 1: being you or the experience of being human
Speaker 1: is happening?
Speaker 1: The meta-context is absolute reality or the
Speaker 1: absolute knowing.
Speaker 1: That's non-dual.
Speaker 1: And when, when you awaken and you reawaken,
Speaker 1: you remember who you are and where you are
Speaker 1: Very easy to forget.
Speaker 1: Most people do so.
Speaker 1: It's only when we awaken and reawaken, and
Speaker 1: reawaken yet again on a regular basis, that
Speaker 1: we can stay on the path and not get
Speaker 1: distracted by this or by that or by
Speaker 1: something else.
Speaker 1: Like I often say, it's easy to wake up and
Speaker 1: it's much easier to fall back to sleep.
Speaker 1: It's easy to wake up, but it's much easier
Speaker 1: to fall back to sleep.
Speaker 1: It's easy to wake up, but it's very hard to
Speaker 1: stay awake.
Speaker 1: So, if you do the work, if you do the hard
Speaker 1: work that you need to do to stay awake,
Speaker 1: then you continue to put one foot in front
Speaker 1: of the other and you won't step in and out
Speaker 1: of higher consciousness and you'll stay in,
Speaker 1: in and out of higher consciousness and
Speaker 1: you'll stay in it and aware of it because
Speaker 1: you'll be giving it the priority that it
Speaker 1: needs to be remembered.
Speaker 1: So, if we say non-duality is oneness, which
Speaker 1: is very common, it's true of it's true, of
Speaker 1: course it's true, but it doesn't really say
Speaker 1: what it is.
Speaker 1: Because, as I was saying, in this absolute
Speaker 1: cognition, in this absolute gnosis, there
Speaker 1: is the mysterious, miraculous knowing of
Speaker 1: all things.
Speaker 1: It doesn't mean that you know this and you
Speaker 1: know that and you know the other thing.
Speaker 1: It doesn't mean omniscience, but it means
Speaker 1: you know the ultimate truth.
Speaker 1: Even if you're still learning about
Speaker 1: relative things and relative reality and
Speaker 1: relative truths and relative perspectives,
Speaker 1: as we all will continue to do, hopefully,
Speaker 1: for as long as we live, the absolute truth
Speaker 1: is the truth that liberates us, because it
Speaker 1: transmits to us, faster than the mind can
Speaker 1: understand the ultimate mystery that
Speaker 1: transcends life and death the secret of
Speaker 1: immortality.
Speaker 1: It's not this or that, it's everything, and
Speaker 1: it's the absolute context, the knowing of
Speaker 1: which changes absolutely everything, of
Speaker 1: which changes absolutely everything.
Speaker 1: We gain access to non-duality and the
Speaker 1: inconceivable and absolute liberation that
Speaker 1: is its gift.
Speaker 1: By letting go of everything else, by
Speaker 1: letting go of absolutely everything else,
Speaker 1: by letting go of everything else, and if we
Speaker 1: have the courage and inspired intention to
Speaker 1: let go of everything else, that mystery
Speaker 1: will begin to reveal itself to us in its
Speaker 1: own time and in its own way, but it will to
Speaker 1: us in its own time and in its own way, but
Speaker 1: it will.
Speaker 1: If you still believe that something else is
Speaker 1: going to make you truly happy and set you
Speaker 1: free, it won't happen.
Speaker 1: That's why I always use the metaphor of
Speaker 1: jumping out of an airplane without a
Speaker 1: parachute.
Speaker 1: As I always say, someone's going to jump
Speaker 1: out of an airplane without a parachute only
Speaker 1: if they have no intention of coming back.
Speaker 1: So non-dual means absolutely everything,
Speaker 1: everything, everything, everything.
Speaker 1: It means letting it all go and having the
Speaker 1: courage to let it all go, having the trust
Speaker 1: to let it all go, and it means really
Speaker 1: wanting to know what the truth is for
Speaker 1: yourself.
Speaker 1: You have to believe that you can know what
Speaker 1: the absolute truth is.
Speaker 1: You have to believe you're capable of it
Speaker 1: and you have to want to know what it is.
Speaker 1: You have to come to the point where you
Speaker 1: feel I will never be able to truly make
Speaker 1: sense out of the human experience unless I
Speaker 1: can realize what the absolute truth is.
Speaker 1: I've always, personally, I've always felt
Speaker 1: that.
Speaker 1: You know, the way it works these days is
Speaker 1: that people tend to become serious seekers
Speaker 1: or seekers not necessarily serious ones,
Speaker 1: but seekers.
Speaker 1: Later in life I realize I'm lost and I'm
Speaker 1: not happy.
Speaker 1: I give up.
Speaker 1: It's a good place to come to, if you mean
Speaker 1: it, but I've always thought and I have a
Speaker 1: habit of liking to think in idealistic
Speaker 1: terms, idealistic utopian terms.
Speaker 1: Then it would be.
Speaker 1: Wouldn't it be wonderful for all of us, for
Speaker 1: our whole species and for the planet, if we
Speaker 1: human beings who are well-educated and
Speaker 1: reasonably well-off could focus on what's
Speaker 1: most important when we're still very young,
Speaker 1: before we mess it all up, because, of
Speaker 1: course, the ultimate context, the meta
Speaker 1: context that I'm speaking about, will help
Speaker 1: us to make sense out of human experience,
Speaker 1: will help us to make sense out of our own
Speaker 1: experience in the best possible way.
Speaker 1: It's like being in a ship, a sailing ship,
Speaker 1: and having to climb to the top of the
Speaker 1: highest mass in order to be able to see
Speaker 1: where you are.
Speaker 1: So if we could begin to do that work when
Speaker 1: we're relatively young, and if we could be
Speaker 1: taught about what's truly important in
Speaker 1: terms of values when we're very young, when
Speaker 1: we could wake up and become enlightened
Speaker 1: when we're still very young, just think of
Speaker 1: the kind of beautiful world we could create
Speaker 1: together A sane world.
Speaker 1: The sane world, not an insane world, but a
Speaker 1: deeply sane world where things made sense
Speaker 1: and where we made very beautiful sense out
Speaker 1: of the gift of life, because we were seeing
Speaker 1: the context of this meta-perspective and
Speaker 1: this absolute perspective.
Speaker 1: But that's not the world we're living in,
Speaker 1: obviously.
Speaker 1: So we tend to begin to wake up later in
Speaker 1: life, after we've stumbled a few times and
Speaker 1: fallen a few times and probably made some
Speaker 1: important mistakes and realized how much we
Speaker 1: don't know and how lost we really are.
Speaker 1: It takes enormous humility to wake up to
Speaker 1: absolute reality, and it takes even more
Speaker 1: humility to stay awake once you've woken up.
Speaker 1: Unfortunately, when some people wake up in
Speaker 1: a genuine way, their ego grabs onto the
Speaker 1: experience and they think they're special.
Speaker 1: Now I've arrived Very dangerous thing to do,
Speaker 1: and especially for us children of
Speaker 1: post-modernity.
Speaker 1: We're all children of post-modernity.
Speaker 1: We tend to have big egos.
Speaker 1: We've been culturally conditioned to think
Speaker 1: a lot of ourselves and to be very
Speaker 1: self-infatuated with the small self.
Speaker 1: It makes it harder to wake up, harder to
Speaker 1: let go.
Speaker 1: So the thing that's so challenging about
Speaker 1: the awakening to enlightened awareness and
Speaker 1: its lead to becoming stabilized and gaining
Speaker 1: access to non-dual gnosis, non-dual
Speaker 1: cognition and non-dual knowing is that we
Speaker 1: have to keep letting go of everything to be
Speaker 1: able to sustain that level of consciousness.
Speaker 1: We've got to keep letting go of everything
Speaker 1: to sustain that level of consciousness.
Speaker 1: Start at the beginning, again back to zero.
Speaker 1: Start at the beginning, again back to zero,
Speaker 1: and again go back to zero.
Speaker 1: And only if there's a huge puncture in your
Speaker 1: ego, a huge spiritual wound of the best
Speaker 1: kind, will you be able to keep letting go
Speaker 1: Because the ego says no, I'm important, I
Speaker 1: exist, I have my needs and the ego does
Speaker 1: have its needs.
Speaker 1: Believe me, you all know that the ego has
Speaker 1: lots my needs and the ego does have its
Speaker 1: needs, believe me.
Speaker 1: You all know that the ego has lots of needs
Speaker 1: and the ego likes to be recognized and
Speaker 1: loved and adored and respected.
Speaker 1: But your true self doesn't need any of
Speaker 1: those things, doesn't need any of those
Speaker 1: things.
Speaker 1: And you, whoever you are, have to make a
Speaker 1: decision which way you're going to go.
Speaker 1: At a certain point, we have to make a
Speaker 1: decision which way we're going to go.
Speaker 1: Is it going to be living the life of the
Speaker 1: small self, being a prisoner of its endless
Speaker 1: fears and endless desires and endless needs,
Speaker 1: or are we going to get to that point that
Speaker 1: few people actually do?
Speaker 1: We get fed up.
Speaker 1: We get fed up with being petty and being
Speaker 1: self-concerned, being small-minded and
Speaker 1: being trapped.
Speaker 1: We want to be free Finally, once and for
Speaker 1: all.
Speaker 1: We want to truly be free.
Speaker 1: And then, and only then, we stop playing
Speaker 1: games.
Speaker 1: By playing games, I mean we think we still
Speaker 1: have time to be less than serious.
Speaker 1: We think we still have time to be less than
Speaker 1: serious.
Speaker 1: absolutely sincere.
Speaker 1: We think we have time to be less than
Speaker 1: absolutely real.
Speaker 1: But when you get to that point that I'm
Speaker 1: speaking about.
Speaker 1: You want to stop playing games, you want it
Speaker 1: to be real and you're willing to face the
Speaker 1: truth, whatever it is going to be.
Speaker 1: I remember when I was about 15.
Speaker 1: It must have been 1970.
Speaker 1: So I was born in 1955.
Speaker 1: And I was with some friends in the country
Speaker 1: Vermont, I think.
Speaker 1: In the country.
Speaker 1: We were in a single house in the country
Speaker 1: and we'd taken a huge amount of LSD Way too
Speaker 1: much for such young people.
Speaker 1: That's what it was like in those days.
Speaker 1: And I remember I was in a very intoxicated
Speaker 1: state of psychedelic awareness and one of
Speaker 1: our friends came to visit us and this
Speaker 1: particular fellow had not ingested the LSD
Speaker 1: with us, so he was not in the altered state
Speaker 1: that we were.
Speaker 1: And this fellow had a particularly big ego.
Speaker 1: He was a very arrogant, overconfident
Speaker 1: narcissist.
Speaker 1: And I remember looking at him as he came in
Speaker 1: and he was speaking to us and, under the
Speaker 1: influence of the psychedelic substance, all
Speaker 1: I could see was his ego and it was so ugly
Speaker 1: I found it unbearable to look at him.
Speaker 1: It was terrifying, even frightening, and
Speaker 1: that ugliness, pettiness and
Speaker 1: small-mindedness and selfishness and
Speaker 1: narcissism lives in all of us.
Speaker 1: And so when we get truly serious about
Speaker 1: waking up, if we ever do if we ever do,
Speaker 1: because a lot of people are interested in
Speaker 1: higher state experiences but they don't
Speaker 1: necessarily want to pay the price of ego
Speaker 1: transcendence.
Speaker 1: But when we get to that point if we ever do,
Speaker 1: we're willing to pay the price for ego
Speaker 1: transcendence we get serious and that's
Speaker 1: when you start living as if you're not
Speaker 1: going to get another chance.
Speaker 1: You know that karma is real and that you
Speaker 1: might not get another chance.
Speaker 1: Karma is real and we might not get another
Speaker 1: chance in this life.
Speaker 1: So, while we want to be loving and kind and
Speaker 1: generous, compassionate and fun loving, but
Speaker 1: there is this deep knowing that this is not
Speaker 1: a game.
Speaker 1: And I'm not trying to say that the human
Speaker 1: experience is not a game, because suffering
Speaker 1: exists, as the Buddha pointed out to all of
Speaker 1: us so passionately, and in life there is
Speaker 1: suffering.
Speaker 1: So I'm not saying that life is not a game
Speaker 1: simply because of the truth of suffering,
Speaker 1: but I'm saying that life is not a game
Speaker 1: because what's happening here, in this
Speaker 1: experiment of consciousness and cognition
Speaker 1: the emergence of consciousness and
Speaker 1: cognition in the universe, in the evolving
Speaker 1: universe is serious.
Speaker 1: In our deepest states of consciousness,
Speaker 1: when we're experiencing our most profound
Speaker 1: moments of revelation.
Speaker 1: It's not a laughing matter.
Speaker 1: These are moments of revelation.
Speaker 1: These are moments of being absolutely
Speaker 1: overwhelmed by how serious it is to be
Speaker 1: alive.
Speaker 1: So it's almost like we're experiencing in
Speaker 1: the very.
Speaker 1: We're becoming conscious of the very fabric
Speaker 1: of creation itself, which is not separate
Speaker 1: from our own self, which is not separate
Speaker 1: from who we are, is deadly serious and
Speaker 1: there's so much joy in that seriousness.
Speaker 1: We become serious people, which means
Speaker 1: sincere people.
Speaker 1: We become very sincere because life is not
Speaker 1: a game, life is not a joke.
Speaker 1: There's so much to be done, so much
Speaker 1: consciousness is lacking, so many of us are
Speaker 1: so lost.
Speaker 1: Every moment is important, really.
Speaker 1: So waking up to this absolute truth and
Speaker 1: this absolute cognition and this absolute
Speaker 1: knowing is truly waking up to what a
Speaker 1: serious business it is to be alive, what a
Speaker 1: huge responsibility it is.
Speaker 1: It's a big responsibility to become
Speaker 1: conscious of consciousness, because when
Speaker 1: you truly become conscious of consciousness,
Speaker 1: to some degree at least, after that you
Speaker 1: have to become an exemplar, because you
Speaker 1: know and you see and you understand and you
Speaker 1: recognize what this is all about, and after
Speaker 1: that point you can't pretend that you don't
Speaker 1: anymore.
Speaker 1: Especially if you have courage.
Speaker 1: You can't pretend that you don't,
Speaker 1: especially if you have courage, you can't
Speaker 1: pretend that you don't.
Speaker 1: Most people, because they're living in a
Speaker 1: small world and a small self, are afraid of
Speaker 1: too much reality.
Speaker 1: They're afraid of too much consciousness,
Speaker 1: they're afraid of the truth, without even
Speaker 1: knowing what the truth is.
Speaker 1: They're afraid of it Because it's
Speaker 1: frightening for someone who's not prepared
Speaker 1: for it.
Speaker 1: To wake up to see the truth, to see how big
Speaker 1: this all is, to see how important this all
Speaker 1: is, most people are scared to death of
Speaker 1: knowing that, of seeing it for themselves.
Speaker 1: So waking up is not something that the ego
Speaker 1: does for its entertainment, even though
Speaker 1: that seems like a lot of people are up to.
Speaker 1: It's like taking on a completely different
Speaker 1: vocation.
Speaker 1: I thought the human experience was about me,
Speaker 1: satisfying my desires and meeting my needs,
Speaker 1: and you realize, no, it never was.
Speaker 1: Never was about you, never was about any of
Speaker 1: us.
Speaker 1: It's about reality itself.
Speaker 1: It's not about me, it's not about you.
Speaker 1: So to be serious about this means that we
Speaker 1: need to make sure that we can awaken, as
Speaker 1: I've been saying, that we can awaken and
Speaker 1: reawaken and reawaken on a regular basis.
Speaker 1: A lot of people speak about experiences
Speaker 1: that they had a long time ago.
Speaker 1: And the first thing that my teacher told me
Speaker 1: when I met him in 1986, was that a memory,
Speaker 1: a beautiful memory of absolute reality is
Speaker 1: not absolute reality, it's a memory.
Speaker 1: It's like looking at a photograph If you
Speaker 1: were in love, if you were madly in love
Speaker 1: with somebody when you were 17 or 18, and
Speaker 1: you have in love, if you were madly in love
Speaker 1: you have a photograph of yourself and
Speaker 1: whoever it was, that photograph contains a
Speaker 1: mere fraction of what your inner experience
Speaker 1: actually was at that time.
Speaker 1: So memories of non-dual experiences are not
Speaker 1: non-dual consciousness itself.
Speaker 1: And my guru made clear to me that hanging
Speaker 1: on to memories of absolute reality tie us
Speaker 1: to, they keep us chained to the mind, and
Speaker 1: what he told me that I needed to do is, if
Speaker 1: I wanted to wake up to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness, I needed to let go of my
Speaker 1: attachment to the memory of what had
Speaker 1: happened to me when I was younger, and I
Speaker 1: was so.
Speaker 1: I was very attached to that experience.
Speaker 1: That experience was the source of my
Speaker 1: inspiration.
Speaker 1: He told me to let it go and without without
Speaker 1: that experience.
Speaker 1: That experience was the source of my
Speaker 1: inspiration.
Speaker 1: It taught me to let it go, and without that
Speaker 1: experience I really had nothing anymore.
Speaker 1: But I did it and that changed everything.
Speaker 1: So we always have to start at the beginning
Speaker 1: every day, back to zero.
Speaker 1: Zero is the jumping off point to everything,
Speaker 1: like taking a bath or a shower Every day,
Speaker 1: going back to zero, starting all over again,
Speaker 1: if we can.
Speaker 1: So this talk is supposed to be about the
Speaker 1: evolution of non-duality, and I've often
Speaker 1: spoken about that and I will now speak
Speaker 1: about it a little bit.
Speaker 1: So the Sorry, andrew, that I interrupt you.
Speaker 1: Your microphone is scratching a little bit
Speaker 1: at your collar here Up here, yeah, and it
Speaker 1: makes a sound.
Speaker 1: The microphone makes a sound.
Speaker 1: So sorry about that, thank you.
Speaker 1: So, in terms of the evolution of
Speaker 1: non-duality, we get into some very
Speaker 1: interesting territory.
Speaker 1: Because when we think about the whole
Speaker 1: notion of oneness, when you think, and then
Speaker 1: again, this is all, we're using the mind
Speaker 1: here, this is the we're using the mind here.
Speaker 1: So this all gets very deceptive and very
Speaker 1: confusing.
Speaker 1: But when you think about oneness, it's not
Speaker 1: oneness, because oneness can't be seen.
Speaker 1: So many of you have heard me tell the story
Speaker 1: about my guru who, before he met his own
Speaker 1: guru, the great Ramana Maharshi was a
Speaker 1: Krishna Bhakta.
Speaker 1: He was a devotee of Krishna and his own
Speaker 1: devotional practice had reached such a high
Speaker 1: level, after being very focused on it for
Speaker 1: many years, that he had visions of Krishna
Speaker 1: coming alive before him and speaking to him.
Speaker 1: So that's a very high level of
Speaker 1: concentration.
Speaker 1: So he had visions of Krishna, of God, but
Speaker 1: he had a sense that there was more.
Speaker 1: So at a certain point in his life he
Speaker 1: started traveling around India, going to
Speaker 1: see all the most famous gurus at the time
Speaker 1: and this would have been the late forties
Speaker 1: telling them can you help me see God?
Speaker 1: And he said every all the gurus he went to
Speaker 1: said yes, I can do this technique, do this
Speaker 1: method, practice this kind of approach.
Speaker 1: And he wanted, he was looking for someone
Speaker 1: who could show him directly God.
Speaker 1: So, apparently, when he asked Ramana the
Speaker 1: question can you show me God?
Speaker 1: Ramana said no, I can't because God is the
Speaker 1: seer.
Speaker 1: So if God is the seer, then me.
Speaker 1: That's very profound, everyone knew it's
Speaker 1: very profound.
Speaker 1: So that means that right now, as you're
Speaker 1: looking at me and I'm looking at all of you,
Speaker 1: the seer is who and what.
Speaker 1: The absolute principle or the Godhead is.
Speaker 1: The Godhead is the seer right now, and
Speaker 1: either that's obvious to you or it's not
Speaker 1: obvious to you, but whether it's obvious or
Speaker 1: not, it's true.
Speaker 1: So the seer, not the seen, is what God, or
Speaker 1: the absolute principle of the Godhead
Speaker 1: actually is the seer, not the seen.
Speaker 1: Now, if you're very identified with your
Speaker 1: small self and your ego, you'll just be
Speaker 1: seeing your ego paying attention to the
Speaker 1: experience of seeing.
Speaker 1: But in the higher and deeper states of
Speaker 1: awakened awareness, you can directly
Speaker 1: experience, even in your own self, but the
Speaker 1: small self disappears and it's possible to
Speaker 1: have that kind of experience.
Speaker 1: Believe me, that the annoying presence, the
Speaker 1: annoying presence of the fears and desires
Speaker 1: of the small self and its consciousness of
Speaker 1: itself can at times, in higher states of
Speaker 1: consciousness and cognition, completely
Speaker 1: disappear and vanish from your awareness.
Speaker 1: So then you're not just aware of awareness,
Speaker 1: or it's not just the consciousness of
Speaker 1: consciousness, but there's an awareness in
Speaker 1: which this non-relative, our absolute
Speaker 1: principle is bearing witness to itself in
Speaker 1: all its inconceivable glory, all its
Speaker 1: inconceivable glory.
Speaker 1: It's not just a moment of quiet, seeing
Speaker 1: where the mind is, it's not just a moment
Speaker 1: of seeing when the mind is quiet, but it's
Speaker 1: a revelation, it's the experience of
Speaker 1: revelation of this absolute principle.
Speaker 1: So this is to repeat something I've been
Speaker 1: saying ever since I started to talk today,
Speaker 1: it's the mysterious cognition of everything
Speaker 1: and nothing simultaneously.
Speaker 1: How can I see and know everything and
Speaker 1: nothing at the same time?
Speaker 1: You can't understand it with the mind, but
Speaker 1: you can know everything and nothing at the
Speaker 1: same time If you're willing to let go of
Speaker 1: this and that and the.
Speaker 1: The presence and consciousness and
Speaker 1: cognition of the absolute transports us
Speaker 1: into another dimension of knowing.
Speaker 1: It's when the seer, which is God, the
Speaker 1: absolute principle, is being seen by who?
Speaker 1: By you, but the you that's doing the seeing
Speaker 1: at that point is not your ego.
Speaker 1: That's what changes everything.
Speaker 1: So the evolving dimension of all this is
Speaker 1: very interesting because the universe, the
Speaker 1: evolving universe, the creative process
Speaker 1: that we call the evolving universe, the
Speaker 1: that we call the evolving universe, all of
Speaker 1: time and space and everything that exists
Speaker 1: within it and that which transcends time
Speaker 1: and space and everything that exists within
Speaker 1: it, is not static, is not static Sum total
Speaker 1: of all of reality, everything that is seen
Speaker 1: and unseen, known and unknown, all manifest
Speaker 1: and unmanifest reality, is not static.
Speaker 1: The unmanifest and the manifest are one and
Speaker 1: not two.
Speaker 1: Manifest reality and unmanifest reality are
Speaker 1: one and not two.
Speaker 1: Whereas unmanifest reality is static and
Speaker 1: unmoving and infinite and timeless and
Speaker 1: formless and beginningless and endless and
Speaker 1: eternal, manifest reality is not static.
Speaker 1: Manifest reality is not a journey of
Speaker 1: becoming.
Speaker 1: It's the evolving universe, it's the
Speaker 1: universe of time and space and form.
Speaker 1: And manifest reality is an evolutionary
Speaker 1: process that's in a state of becoming more
Speaker 1: complex over time.
Speaker 1: It's on a journey of becoming.
Speaker 1: So the manifest and the unmanifest are one
Speaker 1: and not two.
Speaker 1: Just like this, as they say in the Buddha
Speaker 1: Dharma, form is emptiness and emptiness is
Speaker 1: form.
Speaker 1: Manifest reality and unmanifest reality are
Speaker 1: one and not two, which means the same thing,
Speaker 1: as form is emptiness and emptiness is form.
Speaker 1: But, as the great Ken Wilber is fond of
Speaker 1: saying, yes, form is emptiness and
Speaker 1: emptiness is form.
Speaker 1: But the world of form is also evolving.
Speaker 1: So the manifest and the unmanifest are one
Speaker 1: and not two.
Speaker 1: Unmanifest reality is static.
Speaker 1: Manifest reality is evolving.
Speaker 1: So if we want to look at the sum totality
Speaker 1: of everything that exists and everything
Speaker 1: that doesn't exist, from an absolute
Speaker 1: perspective, we can no longer distinguish
Speaker 1: between manifest and unmanifest, because
Speaker 1: manifest and unmanifest are one and not two.
Speaker 1: So because the manifest and the unmanifest
Speaker 1: are one and not two, because the manifest
Speaker 1: is indeed part of an evolving developing
Speaker 1: process in a state of becoming, and we
Speaker 1: realize that from a non-dual perspective,
Speaker 1: where the manifest and the unmanifest and
Speaker 1: we're not two.
Speaker 1: The reality as a whole is not static but is
Speaker 1: in a state of becoming and, to use
Speaker 1: religious, mythic language, it's fun
Speaker 1: because then we get to make statements like
Speaker 1: God if God.
Speaker 1: It's fun because then we get to make
Speaker 1: statements like God if God means which is a
Speaker 1: mythic term if we use the word God to mean
Speaker 1: the sum total.
Speaker 1: God is the sum totality of everything that
Speaker 1: exists and everything that doesn't exist.
Speaker 1: When we start, when we introduce some new
Speaker 1: information which tells us that that god is
Speaker 1: actually evolving, you say what god is
Speaker 1: evolving?
Speaker 1: Wow, the sum totality of everything that
Speaker 1: exists and everything that doesn't exist is
Speaker 1: on a developmental journey of becoming more
Speaker 1: of what it can be.
Speaker 1: And then, to explore the meaning and
Speaker 1: significance of non-duality a little bit
Speaker 1: more deeply, we realize that I am and you
Speaker 1: are not separate from that one, which is
Speaker 1: not two, as Vedanta tells us.
Speaker 1: I am, that the ultimate truth about the
Speaker 1: nature of reality in Vedanta is that I am,
Speaker 1: that I am the only one that there is.
Speaker 1: There's only one, I, in the universe, and
Speaker 1: you and I and all of us are that one I,
Speaker 1: without a second, and that one I is
Speaker 1: evolving and you and I are not separate
Speaker 1: from that process of becoming, of absolute
Speaker 1: becoming.
Speaker 1: So where does that leave us?
Speaker 1: Neither here or there.
Speaker 1: When you realize that God is becoming, that
Speaker 1: she's on a journey of becoming, then it
Speaker 1: includes everything and excludes nothing,
Speaker 1: the deepest interior dimension of which is
Speaker 1: your own deepest states of subjective
Speaker 1: awareness.
Speaker 1: This whole experience of being human
Speaker 1: becomes very interesting, much more
Speaker 1: interesting than we usually is, because
Speaker 1: when you really wake up, you begin to not
Speaker 1: only understand these things with your mind,
Speaker 1: but feel these things with your soul, and
Speaker 1: you can become so enthralled in the
Speaker 1: interdimensional complexity of this process
Speaker 1: that you can forget delightfully the
Speaker 1: narrative of your, of this process, that
Speaker 1: you can forget delightfully the narrative
Speaker 1: of your small self, because you become so
Speaker 1: consumed with this cosmic, centric
Speaker 1: perspective on your own identity and on the
Speaker 1: nature of reality itself.
Speaker 1: So, to repeat and this is difficult stuff,
Speaker 1: I understand that absolute reality itself
Speaker 1: is evolving.
Speaker 1: So, in our attempt to actually understand
Speaker 1: the meaning of non-duality in 2021, the
Speaker 1: most interesting part of the understanding,
Speaker 1: the emerging understanding of non-duality
Speaker 1: is that non-duality itself, which is
Speaker 1: absolute oneness and not-to-ness, is not
Speaker 1: static but is an evolving process itself
Speaker 1: and it's absolute.
Speaker 1: And you and I are not in any way separate
Speaker 1: from and we're not separate from this
Speaker 1: process, not just at a biological level,
Speaker 1: but at the levels of our deepest
Speaker 1: experiences of subjective awareness, our
Speaker 1: deepest felt and recognized experience of
Speaker 1: conscious awareness, our deepest felt and
Speaker 1: recognized experience of conscious
Speaker 1: awareness.
Speaker 1: The consciousness of consciousness itself
Speaker 1: is not happening in a static context, but
Speaker 1: it's happening in an evolving context.
Speaker 1: And it gets even more interesting when you
Speaker 1: realize that the seer, the one who is
Speaker 1: seeing the evolutionary process itself from
Speaker 1: the steepest place of interiority, is the
Speaker 1: absolute itself as you.
Speaker 1: How much more interesting than that can it
Speaker 1: become?
Speaker 1: So you have to be God to know.
Speaker 1: As you can see, there's no relief in this
Speaker 1: kind of awakening.
Speaker 1: There's no relief because it's unbearable.
Speaker 1: Too much consciousness, too absolute, too
Speaker 1: overwhelming, too much truth.
Speaker 1: It too much truth, it's unbearable.
Speaker 1: It may be ecstatic and it may be liberating,
Speaker 1: but it's also unbearable because it's so
Speaker 1: much truth to bear without being crushed by
Speaker 1: it.
Speaker 1: So I am.
Speaker 1: That is no longer a safe place, because the
Speaker 1: that that I am in this new evolutionary
Speaker 1: context is in a state of becoming so.
Speaker 1: The train has not stopped moving.
Speaker 1: It's moving forward and in our deepest
Speaker 1: moments of higher consciousness, we realize
Speaker 1: that who's at the wheel?
Speaker 1: You are Not as your small self, of course,
Speaker 1: but as the true self, as the authentic self,
Speaker 1: as the one without a second.
Speaker 1: It's only you.
Speaker 1: You've been there the whole time, you just
Speaker 1: didn't realize it.
Speaker 1: So form is emptiness and emptiness is form,
Speaker 1: and the world of form is evolving.
Speaker 1: Try to remember that every day, form is
Speaker 1: emptiness and emptiness is form, and the
Speaker 1: world of form is evolving in the context of
Speaker 1: the two truth doctrine, which tells us that
Speaker 1: there's a distinction between relative
Speaker 1: reality and absolute reality.
Speaker 1: Relative reality is real, it's real, but
Speaker 1: it's only relatively real.
Speaker 1: And absolute reality is real, but it's
Speaker 1: absolutely real.
Speaker 1: So that which is absolutely real exists on
Speaker 1: a completely different level of
Speaker 1: significance in the context of a
Speaker 1: hierarchical perspective and orientation.
Speaker 1: Absolute reality is more real.
Speaker 1: Therefore, it's more significant for you
Speaker 1: and for me.
Speaker 1: So the absolute reality is the sum total of
Speaker 1: everything that exists and everything that
Speaker 1: doesn't exist.
Speaker 1: All of unmanifest and manifest reality are
Speaker 1: one and not two.
Speaker 1: All of manifest reality are.
Speaker 1: All of manifest and unmanifest reality are
Speaker 1: one and not two.
Speaker 1: Form is emptiness and emptiness is form.
Speaker 1: But the world of form, which means manifest
Speaker 1: reality, is evolving, which means that the
Speaker 1: energy and intelligence that created the
Speaker 1: universe, which is the absolute principle,
Speaker 1: which is the Godhead, is in a process of
Speaker 1: becoming.
Speaker 1: It's not just the universe itself, it's in
Speaker 1: a state of becoming evolutionary, becoming.
Speaker 1: The energy and intelligence that gave rise
Speaker 1: to the evolving universe is not separate
Speaker 1: from it and is therefore also evolving,
Speaker 1: which means the mind of God, or mind of the
Speaker 1: creative principle is also in the process
Speaker 1: of becoming more complex.
Speaker 1: If this is true and it sure seems to me
Speaker 1: that it is this means that we have a lot of
Speaker 1: catching up to do.
Speaker 1: Catching up means realizing all these
Speaker 1: things for ourselves and then endeavoring
Speaker 1: with great humility to take responsibility
Speaker 1: for the implications of what it means to be
Speaker 1: a conscious human being who's aware of the
Speaker 1: absolute truth I am.
Speaker 1: That, in fact, doesn't make life easier.
Speaker 1: It makes life a lot harder, but only for
Speaker 1: good reasons.
Speaker 1: So as this absolute, as the conscious
Speaker 1: awareness of this absolute principle
Speaker 1: emerges in our conscious experience, as
Speaker 1: I've been saying in different ways,
Speaker 1: everything else falls away.
Speaker 1: There's only that.
Speaker 1: There's only that the small self is nowhere
Speaker 1: to be seen.
Speaker 1: Its dramas and its stories is nowhere to be
Speaker 1: seen.
Speaker 1: When you awaken to absolute reality, deeply
Speaker 1: and profoundly.
Speaker 1: Relative reality begins to disappear per
Speaker 1: time.
Speaker 1: So if the awakening to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness tells us that we are God or the
Speaker 1: absolute principle, if that's the
Speaker 1: revelation, I am that, and now we've come
Speaker 1: to understand that that is evolving.
Speaker 1: That's what the evolution of non-duality
Speaker 1: means.
Speaker 1: And of course, it is an absolutely
Speaker 1: soul-expanding revelation to begin to
Speaker 1: cognize that, to begin to recognize it, to
Speaker 1: begin to directly experience the truth of
Speaker 1: it.
Speaker 1: And, as I was just saying, what's even a
Speaker 1: bigger challenge is to endeavor to take
Speaker 1: responsibility for what that might mean
Speaker 1: about being a conscious human being who
Speaker 1: knows these things, who's aware of it.
Speaker 1: I think the great Sri Aurobindo called it
Speaker 1: being a, referred to as being a Gnostic
Speaker 1: being.
Speaker 1: So, relative reality, which is only half
Speaker 1: the picture, a part of the picture, is
Speaker 1: important.
Speaker 1: The domain and dominion of the relatively
Speaker 1: real is important.
Speaker 1: It's a big part of the picture of what's
Speaker 1: true and what's real.
Speaker 1: Relative reality is real, but when you
Speaker 1: awaken to absolute reality and become
Speaker 1: conscious of absolute reality, that which
Speaker 1: is merely relatively real becomes less
Speaker 1: important to us, plays less of a role in
Speaker 1: our lives, and that's the whole point.
Speaker 1: So when my relative identity and its story
Speaker 1: becomes less important to me and my
Speaker 1: absolute identity and its story becomes
Speaker 1: more important to me, that has a huge
Speaker 1: effect on who I am, how I show up, what I'm
Speaker 1: doing here and why I'm doing it.
Speaker 1: And it's not a small shift, it's a big one.
Speaker 1: Enlightenment doesn't exist outside us.
Speaker 1: Enlightened awareness doesn't exist outside
Speaker 1: us.
Speaker 1: It exists within all of us.
Speaker 1: And when consciousness recognizes itself
Speaker 1: and awakens to itself, then the self,
Speaker 1: that's the container for that consciousness,
Speaker 1: begins to reflect the light of its own
Speaker 1: awakened awareness.
Speaker 1: And that's when we change.
Speaker 1: That's when the small self no longer has
Speaker 1: dominion over the body, the mind or the
Speaker 1: personality Still there, but it's no longer
Speaker 1: in the driver's seat I received.
Speaker 1: So oneness is evolving.
Speaker 1: That's the extraordinary thing Even now,
Speaker 1: after all these years.
Speaker 1: It's not a new idea for me, it's not a new
Speaker 1: truth, but when I think about it, when I
Speaker 1: speak about it, it is as mesmerizing and as
Speaker 1: mind-boggling to me as it was when I first
Speaker 1: learned about this many years ago.
Speaker 1: When I first learned about this many years
Speaker 1: ago.
Speaker 1: Because when we use the G word.
Speaker 1: When we use the God word, we're always
Speaker 1: thinking of the static principle.
Speaker 1: In some way, shape or form the
Speaker 1: consciousness of the God principle or the
Speaker 1: notion of the God principle usually
Speaker 1: represents in the eye of the mind is static
Speaker 1: that which is static and unchanging, and
Speaker 1: permanent and infinite.
Speaker 1: But when we realize and discover that that
Speaker 1: absolute principle is not static, but when
Speaker 1: we realize and discover that that absolute
Speaker 1: principle is not static, it unhinges our
Speaker 1: perspective, taking on nature of the
Speaker 1: absolute in the most delightful and
Speaker 1: extraordinary ways.
Speaker 1: So a lot of people have questions like well,
Speaker 1: what is what would be the?
Speaker 1: what would be the most perfect expression
Speaker 1: of an integration between these absolute
Speaker 1: and relative levels?
Speaker 1: I don't know For someone like me.
Speaker 1: I've always been more interested in the
Speaker 1: absolute than I have in the relative.
Speaker 1: So I'm not interested in any kind of
Speaker 1: perfectly balanced integration.
Speaker 1: The more of the absolute that there is, the
Speaker 1: happier I am.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 1: A lot of people want to know what does the
Speaker 1: absolute principle look like?
Speaker 1: It looks like you.
Speaker 1: It doesn't look like your ego.
Speaker 1: It looks just like you do.
Speaker 1: And the question is, where is that absolute
Speaker 1: self, that true self, that authentic self.
Speaker 1: So it was, rightale was right here, right
Speaker 1: here, where else could it be?
Speaker 1: Well, very good, I did my best to try and
Speaker 1: convey a little bit of my understanding of
Speaker 1: the all dharma discussions.
Speaker 1: For me is not the revelation of the
Speaker 1: absolute itself, which, of course, is
Speaker 1: completely life-changing and totally
Speaker 1: liberating, but it's the implications for
Speaker 1: what it means to be a human being that I
Speaker 1: find the most compelling.
Speaker 1: If I am God in this absolute principle,
Speaker 1: awakening to itself and becoming conscious
Speaker 1: of itself, which is the form of my mind,
Speaker 1: body and personality, and what does that
Speaker 1: revelation mean about who I am and how I
Speaker 1: should be living out this human experience?
Speaker 1: That's the most important question.
Speaker 1: Not the experience itself, which reveals to
Speaker 1: us what the truth is, but what are the
Speaker 1: implications of this experience for being a
Speaker 1: human being, for being me?
Speaker 1: What does it mean?
Speaker 1: What does it imply About how I'm supposed
Speaker 1: to show up, act and react and engage with
Speaker 1: this world?
Speaker 1: What should my values be?
Speaker 1: All about my values?
Speaker 1: If I am God of this absolute principle of
Speaker 1: awakening to itself through the body, mind,
Speaker 1: personality of my own self, what dramatic
Speaker 1: effect would this have on my values as a
Speaker 1: relative personality.
Speaker 1: Non-duality Implications are profound, I
Speaker 1: think, in terms of evolutionary non-duality.
Speaker 1: We begin to understand that especially when
Speaker 1: we look at the idea of non-duality and
Speaker 1: evolutionary non-duality in the context of
Speaker 1: pantheism and panentheism.
Speaker 1: Pantheism means that the universe is God
Speaker 1: and panentheism means God is the evolving
Speaker 1: universe plus that which transcends the
Speaker 1: evolving universe.
Speaker 1: So if we look at this in the context of an
Speaker 1: understanding of panentheism and we realize
Speaker 1: that there's no such thing as an absolute
Speaker 1: principle that stands separate from its own
Speaker 1: creative process, that begins to mean that
Speaker 1: as we evolve, god and the absolute
Speaker 1: principle evolve simultaneously and the
Speaker 1: non-dual implications of that are mind
Speaker 1: boggling.
Speaker 1: God evolves through me, as me.
Speaker 1: Once again, the implications for
Speaker 1: understanding of non-duality then become
Speaker 1: very profound.
Speaker 1: So that puts as sentient beings, as
Speaker 1: consciously self-aware sentient beings.
Speaker 1: This pushes up right against the very edge,
Speaker 1: or what Ken Wilber likes to call the
Speaker 1: leading edge, of the creative process, and
Speaker 1: I can't think of a more exciting and more
Speaker 1: excruciating place to be than the very
Speaker 1: leading edge of the creative process itself
Speaker 1: that is beginning to cognize itself,
Speaker 1: beginning to become conscious of itself in
Speaker 1: new ways through this biological organism
Speaker 1: that has these miraculous capacities for
Speaker 1: self-reflective awareness.
Speaker 1: God evolves through me, as me, through us,
Speaker 1: as us.
Speaker 1: And so when you, when you, if we explore
Speaker 1: this idea of evolutionary non-duality a
Speaker 1: little bit more deeply, you begin to
Speaker 1: realize it's.
Speaker 1: It's hard, heartbreaking, because you
Speaker 1: realize this.
Speaker 1: There's no guarantees here.
Speaker 1: The absolute principle is trying to figure
Speaker 1: this out with us, so there's no guarantees
Speaker 1: of what the outcome is going to be.
Speaker 1: Our individual and collective evolution to
Speaker 1: higher and deeper levels of consciousness
Speaker 1: and cognition and spiritual realization are
Speaker 1: imperative for the evolution of the cosmos
Speaker 1: to unfold in the best possible way.
Speaker 1: Things can go wrong and do go wrong and are
Speaker 1: going wrong, and the creative principle is
Speaker 1: not separate from the forces that are
Speaker 1: pulling us in what we would consider to be
Speaker 1: the right direction or the wrong direction.
Speaker 1: It's all part of the absolute truth that's
Speaker 1: unbearable to begin to let in.
Speaker 1: So there are no transcendental guarantees
Speaker 1: or should-bes beyond what is and beyond
Speaker 1: what can be right now.
Speaker 1: So if you let that in, you will feel
Speaker 1: yourself deeply inspired to wake up.
Speaker 1: If you really let in what that means?
Speaker 1: You feel yourself incredibly inspired to
Speaker 1: wake up because you realize that, from the
Speaker 1: deepest point of view, that the evolution
Speaker 1: of the interior of the universe, the
Speaker 1: evolution of the interior of the universe,
Speaker 1: the evolution of the interior of the cosmos
Speaker 1: depends upon you and me getting it right.
Speaker 1: So the implications are profound indeed and
Speaker 1: quite overwhelming, thank you.
Speaker 1: So if God doesn't exist outside the process
Speaker 1: that she gave rise to, then it's up to us,
Speaker 1: her creation, to do the hard work that she
Speaker 1: can only do through us.
Speaker 1: That's the profound meaning of evolutionary
Speaker 1: non-duality.
Speaker 1: Those are the profound meaning of
Speaker 1: evolutionary non-duality.
Speaker 1: Those are the profound implications, and
Speaker 1: they are big.